Dennis typicalippa says he's the
happiest man in the world he's an elder
of the manupi clan one of the
traditional owners of tiwi islands off
Australia's North Coast and on Wednesday
they won what's being described as a
David vs Goliath Court battle against a
major oil and gas company
Mr typicalippa complains that he and
other traditional owners of the tiwi
islands
was not consulted
the judge quashed the approval of a 3.6
billion project by Santos limited to
drill for gas about 140 kilometers off
the tiwi islands he said the regulator
couldn't have been reasonably satisfied
the company had carried out the
necessary consultations
last month the judge traveled to the
islands and heard firsthand about the
indigenous group's spiritual connections
to the land and sea
and the hunting and Gathering activities
passed down from their ancestors
carry on that tradition
Al to our kids and hope that they can
sort of continue on that Journey
Santos had argued the tiwi Islanders
weren't relevant stakeholders in the
project so didn't need to be involved in
talks Dennis disagreed respect
it's all a better respect for me you
know it's really disappointing that they
never came to us enough face to face
it's been a controversial case with
protests by indigenous activists outside
Court in the lead-up to the decision
they're destroying the Earth
we are the cultural Giants we're the
original people from this land the
lawyer says the ruling is Monumental and
could have not only local but Global
implications for how big companies
engage with First Nations groups
there's lots of work to be done there's
a lot of um you know proposed gas
projects in the territory and uh it's
absolutely the case that the fight
doesn't end
drilling has been suspended for now
while Santos decides whether to appeal
or put in a new application the company
says it's disappointed with the decision
calling it damaging to investor
confidence but the manupi clan is still
celebrating Dennis says he did it for
his ancestors alexio Brian Al Jazeera